[Music]
guess what time it is
it's our favorite reddit and my the
[ __ ] here we go
mi D [ __ ] for not telling the guy I
was dating that my daughter is biracial
it's already starting like you're not a
natural but so far this is great okay
part of the KKK he really believes in
this stuff but you know what I respect
him I started dating this guy man in
January of this year we went on a few
dates here and there but nothing serious
in March we all went into lockdown so he
and I text back and forth spoke on a
phone and video chatted our restrictions
just started to lift here and I was
really liking this guy so we decided to
hang out and go on a hike after the hike
we went back to his place to watch a
movie and have dinner and probably [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] I was at his peace
please for a couple hours and we started
talking about our daughters he also has
a daughter who was close in mine too age
and he had never met my daughter because
I don't bring men around my child unless
it's a serious relationship okay he
began showing me pics of his daughter so
I did the same we're gonna swipe it
through pics of her he asked me if she
was mixed I told him yeah and that was
my and my ex-husband is black he didn't
started telling me that I should have
told him this in the beginning I didn't
understand because I've never
experienced this before
I've always been up front with a few
guys I dated that I have a child but I
never thought it was important for me to
make sure to add that she's biracial he
started saying that he didn't think he
could go on dating me because it's not
he's very against interracial dating and
they would never accept him dating
someone with a child who's mixed he's he
kept saying over and over that I should
have told him because now he's hurt
because he really liked me I ended up
going off on him and left he's been
texting me to apologize and people just
apologize yeah I guess to apologize to
her apologize
he was like he was texting me to
apologize he's apologized all caps your
phone goes Bing Bing Bing knees like
apologize apologize
oh man you say sorry for me so far he's
in the wrong so that seemed like
something's a Jif of a girl being like
when the coming I can't believe I was
asking about brothers with a black guy
anyways he goes I ended up she says I
ended up blocking him I told some of my
friends and family members about this
and the response has been about half and
half
so this is the part that kind of right
some say I should have told him while
others say he's the [ __ ] I haven't
dated much since my divorce so now I'm
wondering if this is something I need to
tell a date right away oh I don't get it
and I don't think I did anything wrong
so I'll let you guys be the judge no she
did nothing wrong
racism got solved a long time ago yeah
it's completely solved but I mean is it
is it because I'm in LA and I that's
just my world imagine if you were only
like a quarter or whatever else right
and then you look at the family photos
and they're like your grandfather was
Asian
why didn't you tell me you're a mixed
person yeah so this guy's worried about
the family album that he's like oh he he
has his own [ __ ] that's all look
everyone people love to do the family
thing it's so easy but blaming on the
family right but he's interacting with
this chick he's along within a
relationship with this chick he doesn't
have to make her feel bad he's like once
every 10 years I'm gonna go the family
yeah right and he could make her feel
good by the way he be like yo I love you
I love your kid this is awesome but your
family's [ __ ] or my family's [ __ ] up
you don't know my family you do that
[ __ ] no so that must mean that those
thoughts are also his thoughts
it's kind of a shocker though because
she thought you know she's like I didn't
really think this will be happening so
she thought she was kind of naive to
think that you know this kind of stuff
didn't happen in her area he's
he's doing everything but saying I am
offended by this which he should say
immediately but at least yeah for her
own sake at least so for her she was
like it didn't even occur to her because
she was more worried about potential
pedophiles having a daughter and
bringing new strangers into the house
also Walt worry about that now I gotta
worry about guys who i'll suck this
guy's dick but you better not be a
pedophile at the wild I feel like that
that's a more of a legit concern than
the whole racist one I think I think I
would think that first was a problem
before going to for me it works in
layers you know I mean like the first
one would be like I just want to make
sure I show my kids the ability and then
the next I would be like well I don't
want to bring strangers around my
daughter because you know this section
but I don't think that would be my first
go to like like I don't want them raping
my kid I'd be like no I just don't want
her to be an [ __ ] or see them
mistreating me you don't mean like okay
like you're watching stepbrothers right
and then it's the beginning opening
scene where the the mom and the dad are
about to hook up and she's like oh I got
taste me I have a dot I got a son and
then he's like I have a son that's four
years old in the zone and start making
out oh just to let you know he's uh yeah
he's like biracial and then he just dips
that be [ __ ] up everything was fine
usually I would think like he would have
dipped if she was a all had a daughter
and he was like I actually think I'm I
don't want that which is still kind of
like weird but it depends on how you
want that but but the funny part is that
he thinks it's news to break to them
right yeah hey just so you know I have a
biracial kid I know I break it to you it
isn't that weird isn't that weird to
talk about your kid and be like hey so I
have this kid so whatever he's into
soccer and he's part black like who who
says who speaks like that you should
never come up cuz it's a pejorative it
is it is cousin like what if he just has
a small dick that's what it is and he
just yeah he just knows the real type oh
I like cousin the biracial has a big one
what's a girl I think
nobody's thing called the last boyfriend
exactly I think he just had a small dick
he was just a second Nelson's the only
one that gets me in this good I got it
now I wouldn't say that
she was trying to say that all black
guys have huge dicks I said the
stereotype no that's what you did that's
what you believe and it's a belief
system in it's funny you have a big dick
that's not true it's a complete myth
very well I guess being in LA sometimes
um we are guilty of being in LA bubble
and Hal Ford and relax
really like when I get introduced to
people and it's I'm not gonna say who
does it more but it's like oh this is my
friend Adam he's a VN you should say who
does it more you just told our single do
we yeah do I take responsibility I take
responsibility I didn't know you're
right I am pretty Arian I think so I
certainly thought so maybe you should
give your eyes Afghan to the team I
don't know I have to right I'm white on
you know what though being Afghan is I
come from the area in mountain range you
are oh really yeah
they are the true area I'm their
variance don't say that [ __ ] [ __ ] say
that [ __ ] blue eyes dude see your fake
geo geo I'm being serious right now
don't [ __ ] say that [ __ ] you don't
have blue eyes I don't listen to I am
Aryan can somebody took that context
we've been striving you've spent four
minutes yelling at everyone that he is
true area did you know that Indians were
also considered area - yeah which
Indians are you talking about Indian Joe
what the [ __ ] maze you're talking about
where did you get that information yeah
I heard that
wait how did hunter what how did them
get caught hands I don't know because
you know we took it over like we always
do we think we did yeah there's the
caucus region I thought they came five
steps right that's like Mongolians and
Shia so we have the caucus moderation
or another thing what we call it is the
Arianna Aryan like Ariana Grande she's
area she's area I thought she was a
Mexican Mexican because he was he was
good on babe
yeah she uh she Starbucks she's
Starbucks yeah she says why does she
could be Aryan Starbuck why are you
sorry I'm sorry that we took it back
from you guys from taking it back from
us I really I was offended but I have
severe apology thank you yeah you know
what's interesting though being Afghan
is a pretty big thing for me and I would
want to parade that race and be like my
friend Afghan Nadeem the dream because I
don't know any it's the Afghan dream
Nadeem that Afghan dream I like anything
that rhymes
I don't get [ __ ] with my name it's cool
because you're the only Afghan person
that I know
Nelson smells then and that's unique man
yeah it's not like Mexican it's like
there's so many Mexicans people that do
it you're not wrong do it to every race
that's not like oh it's not only white
people do that that's what I say though
cuz I find it fascinating everytime he
introduces me to his friends it's like
oh look at this geo she's Mexican no I
say is gee I think she's Greek or some
[ __ ]
well they see know my name yeah I'm a
good friend
that's pretty what did you say like oh
that's my friend geo geo I would do that
Xuan I wouldn't remember their name and
I was like [ __ ] I got to remember their
names I would introduce them to other
people but I knew the other person's
name so like Luke a I don't know his
name I'd be like net I'd be like hey
meet my friend net and then I'd wait for
you to introduce yourself and then you
say your name doesn't introduce
themselves just change the subject
Oh Chris this is my wife right right
do you like this she calls you Nance cuz
I think it sounds like testicles call
her nodes know she started first
but I've been bitten called Mads and
everybody calls me nuts Oh balls
really yeah I have so many nicknames
what's up what's the other one
hairy nutsack no it gets completely bad
with all the Dom from Saddam nads native
name man my dad calls me Nate man this
is a [ __ ] ton I don't like all those the
dream to the in the dream that's better
sexy I get that one a lot yeah I've
never heard anyone say that yeah
wait is your handle still in the deme is
a terrorist what was that from yeah yeah
the dream where's the dream come from
everyone just called as it rhymes
yeah I put the call everyone likes the
Liam the dream anyone I just prefer to
call you math can friend it's easier to
say that always you're starting to see
the math I'm afraid of you know oh my
god lightly buzz you're so Greek to me
it's crazy there's God have you done
your 23andme yeah there's no Greek in
there
I know wait what are you like 60 percent
white pretty much practically white
there's Greek and white for sure they're
European Greek yogurt yep we love it
what is white I have no idea dude all
right say Florida and white yeah those
are my people dude not your people those
are my people
Florida fine you can take them
[Music]